this is a production of Cornell
University
so it's nice to have the wonderful
affection and thank you for having me
here today
talk to you about my work where I'm
going to describe to you how they
identify tomato receptors that we call
flagellum
sensing Greek and it perceives the
peptides by 2:28 and so I just wanted
not just was a huge retirement project
and especially emphasized there are two
postdocs in Greg's lab in this project
we couldn't have done any of the work
without seasoned Strickler who's here
today thank you
there's a virus analysis we did a lot of
data review for us and also we have two
chemistry students joshua silly and
Enosh Dority who were really
instrumental in some of our development
of chemical groups that are talking
about so I'll start by reminding you of
the overview of plant immunity and so we
have on the surface of a plant cell
these pattern recognition receptors or
PRRS that are responsible for perceiving
pathogens and I'm going to use the
example of Pseudomonas which is a
bacterial pathogen and it has a
flagellum and a part of the flagellum is
this conserved region called microbe
associated molecular patterns from vamps
that are perceived by these cell surface
receptors and initiated intracellular
signaling that include map kinase
cascade and that lead to translational
programming that leads to counter
trigger community and this kind of
triggered immunity is important for
inhibiting the growth of pathogen of
course pathogens have been able to serve
the system through these of effectors
that type three effectors that are
injected into the plant cell by the
second secretion system and these
effectors once they're inside the stop
and then interfere with this pattern of
triggered immunity and in the case of a
TRP GOP in your PTO - effectors and
Pseudomonas that we studied in tomato
these specifically inhibit this pattern
recognition receptor complex activity
and so thereby it inhibits pattern
trigger techniques and now of course the
plant has to fight back and so in tomato
these two effectors are recognized by
the resistance protein complex pto and
that then leads to effect your trigger
community and program cell death that
stops the spread of pathogens so today
we're specifically focus on this very
initial events of recognition that's
happening on the plant cell surface so
entire community we have these cell
surface receptors and these are
transmembrane receptors and the majority
of them is ones I'm showing today all
have inter cellular protein kinases and
these extracellular domains so before in
the last slide I had Apple s 2 which is
probably the best characterized receptor
in plants poor immunity and so FL s 2
works with the co-receptor back 1 and
recognizes
- which is a region of rejection now
this is a fairly well conserved
receptors throughout plants but there
are several examples of receptors that
are found in very specific plant groups
or families so in the case of the efr
receptor that recognizes elf 18 which is
from the elongation factor tu my groups
this is only found in recipes seeing
stone crab boxes another example up so
these are all examples of these Lucille
interviews afterlife cases which are
indicated in a single green domains we
also have other ones including the life
symptom a food containing proteins such
as the serfs which connects chitin and
I'll bring up that this was a new
receptor that was just published
yesterday plan technology so this
actually recognizes LPS the blue
polysaccharides and its receptors
follower and it's a leptin s domain and
so what's key and what sort of
conserving all of these is that
downstream since these are all protein
kinases they activate kinase Cascades
they include transcriptional
reprogramming and this all leads to to
our basal difference and so I'm going to
talk a little bit more about these two
peptides complex when you see that
and this other new peptide that was only
identified about a year and a half ago
from tomato cults like 228 this is also
from flagellin answer for from step back
for a second to talk a little bit about
human reflectors it's been known that
there's actually two flagella receptors
in mammalian systems you have an extra
cellular receptor called tlr5 that
recognizes one portion of the gel and
you have an intracellular protein
complex that recognizes the second
portion of the gel what's kind of cool
is actually if you look at the structure
and what the tomato receptors seem to
recognize we actually again hachi
portions the flag 22 region that's
recognized by Atlas - and we have a
circuit region like 228 that's
recognized by a priestly unknown
receptor at the West group and so one
early hypothesis when we first
identified this newman's was well this
could actually both of these peptides
could be recognized by the same proteins
so in other words the tomato apple s
koutou could just be modified in such a
way to recognize the post so we tested
that hypothesis pretty early on and what
we could find was in fact when you
silent cephalus - and tomato and need
treatment 5:22 you see a reduced
response to this peptide but there's no
difference when you treat with the
slight g28 subtype
so this seems to provide evidence that
in fact we have two different receptors
of tomato that are recognizing the same
protein that's different portions of a
protein so just to give you some
evidence that flight 228 Ashley is
as a man so that it's actually juicy
transcription change in the plants so
her mostly in her laughter she gave a
talking back in the fall he was did a
lot of experiments working with mammoths
and juicers tomato and looking at the
script and so I just like knowledge a
early actually did a reanalysis at some
of this data and that's what I'm showing
you today
what he did is that what we see is that
looking at the number of genes induced
in tomato upon treatment with Flex 228
we have more than 2200 but if we look in
divided further treatments such as when
we treat with student bonus fluorescence
which is an epi inducer 86 of the
percent of the genes that are
transcripts with upregulated are
overlapping with the genes that are
identified 228 so this would have
suggests that one of the major camps in
fluorescence is probably flagellant and
again in five to twenty a treatment is
giving us that same response when we
treat with a disarm strain of
Pseudomonas syringae half of our
communities thousand we see that ninety
percent of the genes that are
upregulated are overlapping again
purpose life-changing and this
percentage goes down in the fully very
reduced in 3,000 because that as I
showed previously is sort of suppressing
PTI induction and then if we don't know
if we have a strain that doesn't deliver
effectors and doesn't have Gellin it's
pretty much escaping recognition we're
not really getting a deduction of PCI
Institute's so when we looked at this
evidence this gave us some confidence
that fly 220
juicing a responsive tomato and so we
were interested in maybe figuring out
what was going on and I happened to be
involved in a project where we were
screening tomato heirloom both of ours
to see infinite variation in the
response to different mints so we have
included black 22 and another 15 CSP 22
but I'm showing you here the data for
flight 228 treatment and what I want to
emphasize here is we saw that there was
one lime yellow carrot as tested that
seemed to have really really reduced
responses to fly and so I wondered was
this an anomaly what was going on and we
actually find other cultivars that were
in fact having a differential response
and so I went through in screening about
200 different tomato cultivars and also
wild species of tomato and what I could
find was actually several cultivars and
a few wild species exceptions that had
this reduced response to fly 228
treatment and so again we have this
yellow pear tomato we have to pick
vanilla foliar accessions so this is the
one
- tomato limits of my own species and
then we had all of these different
tomato cultivars that all show that this
extremely reduced response and in fact
when you look at the responsibility
isn't anything there that's just a
background and so we were very excited
and decided this really set us up for a
really nice genetics approach where I
used yellow careful Tamar that not
responder as one of my parents and the
salon improvement William L able to even
known as the other parent what was
really nice is we actually have genomes
and both parents so that this actually
doing the genetics really didn't isolate
Iran so we have is we actually did
across and looked at the phenotype of
the F ones and so what we see if we
treat this like 22 for either yellow
pair the other parents Valley 1589 or
the f1 hybrids they all respond equally
well to fight with each other but now we
treat the flight 228 yellow pair is
completely insensitive to the peptide
but the LA 1589 in the f1 responding so
now the set us up to do about
fingerprint analysis so I showed you the
phenotype of the f1 movement to the f2
we had a nice segregation of the
phenotype where we had responsive plants
and non-responsive plants and so we
from the responsive plants and the idea
was that if we could go and sequence the
genomes we wanted to look specifically
for regions of the genomes where we had
snips that correspond to only the yellow
hair parent but not to the other la 1689
parent and again because we had the
genome sequences for both of these this
actually ended up being fairly
straightforward and so this is where
Suzy comes in so we developed this
analysis pipeline and I just want to
walk you through it so we again group
the susceptible plants and then we sent
the DNA off for next generation Illumina
sequencing and then Susie that sequence
processing at that data where she
trimmed the reads and filtered and then
she mapped those reads on to the par
yellow card genome so that she could
call this snips and then what she ended
up doing is looking for regions where
the selenium Ethan Allen Williams
specific snips were located and then
that allows some candidates so I'm going
to show you an example of what this
output data looks like and so for 11 or
12 chromosomes this is generally of the
day to look like we're looking at the
percentage of LA 1589 snips and so if we
see no linkage to our trait of interest
we should see 50% and that's generally
what you see obviously you have a little
bit of wiggling in the data but what we
see is generally have 50% snip ratio and
so again about 11 of the 12 chromosomes
look this one chromosome instead of had
a suppressed region where we had very
very few LA
right in here and this correspondent to
about 2.5 million base region and when
we looked at the genes there we actually
found 9 receptor like kinase genes which
was a sort of candidate protein that we
were expecting and so looking at these
nine genes I didn't design primers
looking at these different portions of
the genome and did a little bit of fine
mapping and when we looked at the
recombination we saw a suppressed
recombination around the region this one
gene but not around these other genes
and so we very tentatively called this
one receptor like kinase gene are
punitive Apple s 3 so tomato has been
really nice in the last few years and
that we have a lot of genetic resources
that have been developed so one of those
resources that's been developed out of
Michigan State in silk wrap a soul cap
sequencing and they took a whole bunch
of different tomato cultivars and
convene Ella Foley of accessions and
they did a snip colony throughout the
genomes and so we could actually mine
this data and what we looked for was
Susie first did a whole genome analysis
so she took all the stats from the whole
genome and develop this tree and what we
can do is we had three cultivars in that
list that were non-responsive
so those three cultivars are not related
if you look at the entire genome so get
these are three cultivars that don't
respond if we just take that region of
interest
ten mega bases around that region we now
see that all of these cultivars now
cluster together so this again gave us
some you know potential evidence that
perhaps this region of the genome was of
interest for us and it could have a
comment
breeding history or common lineage we
next then went to different Solana's
species so I put it out tomato of course
response to fly 228 treatment we also
know potato and pepper also respond but
petunia that's not and so now we have
genome sequences of all of these so we
can actually go into the genomes and ask
what do they have this one candidates
plus 3G and really interesting Lee we
have the tomato ls3 candidate we have
pepper and we have potato but if you
look to tune unit and actually been
comida and do not have G so this again
was some evidence suggesting that maybe
that this was the gene and it was a
newly arisen gene that was not present
in it came about after the divergence of
petunia and depression you have
permanent fissile antennas
okay so this is a whole lot of let's go
back to the gene what it is so it has
two exons i'm opened it as we've
sequenced all of those different
cultivars to see what was going on in
this gene and what we found is that in
yellow pair the six other tomato
cultivars and in one of the
we have a horrid experience in machine
and so actually the one base pair
dilution is sufficient because that
causes an average stop and so we would
predict actually that in all of these
cultivars and exceptions this is
actually indelible and then we have one
other that was very interesting so in
the coupe Anila folium la 3 7 3 we
actually had what appeared to be a full
length encoding gene but there were four
nonsynonymous snips and so you can
actually see if you go back to the data
we see that this la 3 7 3 wasn't really
a null it seemed to have some response
but it was greatly reduced so this is
kind of another really interesting a
little for us to study the first before
all of this we have to actually show
what is when it's the gene doing what is
it encoding not spraying with me instead
we've seen pictures Pete for several
minutes so it has 27 extracellular to
see which repeats transmembrane domain
and apprentice domain and now when we go
and actually look at what it looks like
on the active available if you take the
openness to back one slide 22 crystal
structure and you put the epaulettes 3
gene on it and thread it it looks very
similar but if you look at the actual
amino acid
only about 35% so while structurally it
looks similar because again the
leucine-rich repeat domains are pretty
conserved as far as their structure the
actual amino acid concentration is
fairly low
and now finally putting it into planta
so what's nice is I can use those yellow
pear Tomatoes to do some work tomato and
what I first did was express this F ls3
gene into yellow pear protoplasts to see
if they're a what's now stew and so if I
just express that for less three we
don't get any activation in that cases
but if we treat with flight 22 as our
control we do get activation if we just
treat with the peptide we don't get
activation either it's only when we have
the SLS three plus the flight 228 we
actually now get activation in that
crate and just as a control if you
remember this EF R and L 15 pair that we
can put this in tomato and we also get Z
so this was suggesting to us that the
gene that we had was probably the right
gene but we wanted to do some further
testing so now we express ethyl ester
unique oceania that the me Anna but you
remember from the trade show did not
have a therapist and so if we put in
ethyl s3 in the slide 228 we get a nice
response and if we put in the EFR and
its cognate legged
team we also get a response but if you
have the wrong receptor like a pairs we
don't see any response so it's not that
just expression of F Allah Street closet
adverts so we had some nice data that
was suggesting that F olestra could be
the receptor but we wanted to do some
further studies so going back to this
model what we had is as I mentioned when
we had this aberrant stop codon in one
of our labels that really didn't do us
very much good but we had this other
nice allele that had for me toxic
changes 3 in leucine-rich repeat remains
and when we looked at that they weren't
really conservative residues it didn't
seem to be really big changes but when
we looked at this fourth one that's
actually in the highly conserved P plus
1 we're doing a 3d to prolene change and
so I apologize it was probably this
amino acid change that was causing this
production in response to be the case
that we were observing and then one
other one I want to mention is that in
cases they have a highly conserved need
to be binding site that's important for
the actual catalytic activity of the
pennies and so in this case it says this
life's unique 77 so we also use this
amino acid to Pro motion events
three and so now sort of making
mutations so we're looking here at total
Ross production if I put in a full list
three into been Samantha and should
apply to twenty eight we get response if
I make this eight to be finding site use
we lose the response and also if I make
the 3d to prolene substitution that I
mentioned again we have a reduced
response that's sort of similar to what
we were seeing in the planets and just
to confirm that what I actually did it
was cloned out the other allele from the
LA 373 which we call F list 3-2 and
similar to what we were seeing from the
actual plant the vanilla folium we see a
reduction in response but it's not no
response and in fact if we take that
allele and we mutate the curling back to
3d we can restore wild a question so
this quote told us a couple of things
but it also really imply that the kinase
domain or Penny's activity is probably
important for the function of F for
sourcing so next we wanted to actually
show that we're getting an induction of
UTI and so what we did for these
experiments was we took them to me on a
plants we infiltrated the leaves with a
criterium that expresses a plus three
and then came back later and treated
with our peptide so this should induce
our immune response we then came in
eight hours later and we challenged the
plant with our BC 3000 in an overlapping
circle and what this allows us to do is
that we look for whether we have cell
death in the overlap
if we don't it means that we didn't
induce an immune response into the
bacteria what if we were able to induce
immunity then we don't see cell death in
that spot
so this allows us to really Pro whether
we are getting a new response from this
receptor and treatment and so a horrible
picture I apologize when you can sort of
see here is that if we infiltrate with
only yfp and do the treatment you see
that we actually have the cell that that
the overlapping area the majority of the
time in this suggesting and that we're
not inducing a clear immune response in
that region if we take the inactive
ethyl ester you on the head a to be
bottom segmentation we again also see
that we have cell death in the
overlapping area
thank you but when we have the vial to
vessel s3 we don't see that we have any
in cell death occurring in that region
so that was suggesting again that we are
getting an immune response that was
being initiated when we had epaulettes 3
plus these have been the engine
okay last part of course is the effector
story because that's really what our lab
focuses on so it's been known that the
effectors ain't dirty to an American to
be suppressed at the last to be needed
signaling and not too surprisingly they
also suppress epaulets through community
link both of your PTO and for a year to
a week and so this is something of
course we're really interested in
exploring in Greg's lab whether this is
going to be the same as what occurs for
F plus 2 or is actually different and
this is something I think teenie
insiders are going to be working on
shortly and never wanted to ask is it
except history Superman depend on that
one
and again as less to Salinas so you
would expect that it would be but we
needed to do the experiments anyway so
if we use both Indiana and we either
have a control silencing or about one
silencing in plants that are signs for
back 1 and Express fos 3 we have a
reduced signal and it's comparable to
what we see through a apart so this was
some preliminary evidence back what was
involved but I was able to recently do
in vivo studies looking at the existence
of eppela strains back one and a complex
using communication and so if I have F
ls3 in fact one expressed in the same
leaf if I am you know precipitate
pulling on the back one I'm able to
detect a Celeste rate but if I have wife
key instead and pull my the P I don't
pull down and so this was again
suggesting that
we were getting a blistering backbone to
insist and complex together and I will
say this is actually after treatment
like the peptide and so again this is
more something else we're very
interested in studying as well but these
Marburg and so the last thing that we
needed to do in order to actually show
that this is in fact the receptor we had
to demonstrate specific binding between
the Lightning of the receptor and so we
did this using some chemistry probes
that were devout through collaboration
with Schroeder's lab and specifically
current postdoc jobs for selling and a
former post our signature Authority and
they came up with these very clever
systems to put on two important chemical
ways the first one is this diary photo
cross linker and the second one is this
alkyne chemistry and so we made two
probes are flight 228 and our flight 22
that had what we call this our handle
and what this allows us to do is that
with the photo diary cross linker beam
use UV light and this will covalently
attack and bond to whatever's close by
the outfit handle allows us to click
demonstrate and with this love you
specifically put on attack but let's
just put on the tag after we've done the
experiments so that the tagging doesn't
interfere with the binding of the probe
to its of the plug into it and so we can
show that putting on this little
chemical group which is actually about
the one-and-a-half amino acids in socks
it's not very thick it didn't affect the
activity of the probes and so now we're
going to show
my job I'll walk you through these
experiments because they're a little
tricky we first expressed Ethel s3 GFP
in our Bentham Jana please
we then harvest micro zones and plasma
membranes to have enrichment of our
protein and to get rid of a lot of the
contaminating cytosolic proteins as well
as our flora bill because that would
soak up the Union radiation and prevent
the downstream analysis so we have our
micro zones that have our ethyl ester
GFP we add our probe and any competitors
and so if there are peptide binds to the
receptor again this photo cross linker
is now in close proximity so that we can
hit it with UV radiation and enough
photo cross links so we have a covalent
linkage between a receptor and our
ligand since we have a gfp-tagged we can
do immuno precipitation to pull down
this complex between the receptor
ligands and now with this click
chemistry handle we can add on anytime
you want but we instead arriving at
biotin so we can use a clip chemistry
action to add on by it to either a and
then allows us to be mutable and looking
for either the GFP or for the bind
so we first could show that the probe
chemistry was working so when we treat
with like 2:28 and the presence of
depthless 3 we get BIOS and label as you
can see through the streptavidin a
trapeze
and we have protein votes so like 22 is
not just a bird and bite you so it
showed that our pro chemistry is
specific and it's not just across the
kid everything and we could also compete
off the signal so when we have our
proflex to 28 in the presence of excess
unlabeled like 228 we lose our signal
and we don't hit the flag 22 so that
would suggest again that we had a very
specific receptor ligand interaction
between our flag to 28 and RS 3 and that
couldn't get rid of this binding by just
adding any goal to the experiment and so
to sort of in summary what we have now
is we have identified eppela street
which is the receptor for flight 228
we've shown that if the signaling
involves back ones a co-receptor and
that activation of the signaling pathway
that leads to the activation of map
kinase cascade as well as transcription
rubyprogram
clint we showed that the signaling
involves the Ross production and the
student monitoring the effectors in AVR
pthe OFI can come in and actually
suppress the signal that which was very
fast I'm gonna go ahead and just again
acknowledge everyone in the group so
again Pat did a lot of the cross-linking
experiments as you long was really
and some of the genetics and also the
cloning of the alleles she was needed
all the bioinformatics work which was
totally essential for this project as
you saw Josh had image did the chemistry
we also worked with Joyce and one of her
tech scape working with some cell
cultures and we also collaborated with
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu